مطار استراتيجي مساند للمطار العسكري
الاول في الخرطوم
يضم قاعده عسكريه جويه تشكل خط الدفاع
الجوي عن شمال ووسط السودان
الجيش السوداني البلاد تمر بمنعطف خطير
بسبب قيام الدعم السريع باشد قواتها داخل
العاصمه وبعض المدن
تحركات الدعم السريع تمت دون موافقه قياده
القوات المسلحه
[موسيقى]
نحذر القوى السياسيه من مخاطر المزايده
بمواقف القوات المسلحه الوطنيه
نجدد التمسك بما تم التوافق عليه في دعم
الانتقال السياسي وفقا لما تم في الاتفاق
الايطالي
طاعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات